hi there today we're looking at asset
distribution networks a generative model
for sets of images by Shuang fetch I
Walter tablet and yellow hell Bautista
Carlos gastrin and Josh M Susskind of
Apple so this paper introduces a
generative model for sets and it does so
in an energy based model fashion it will
have an encoder decoder a in form of a
generator it will have a discriminator
and it will help all kinds of math but
the end result is an immortal that can
generate sets of images and buy sets we
mean it can generate different kind of
views on the same identity of image and
you'll see what that means and it can
generate even sets that it has never
seen before which makes it different
from a class conditional Gann or
something like this so if I can't really
describe it on a high level in a very
concise fashion you'll just have to
stick around and see what's going on
right here yeah so if you like content
like this feel also free to share it out
and leave it alike tell me in the
comments what you like this is going to
be a fairly math heavy paper and I'll
try my best to kind of distill it down
to what's happening because ultimately
it's not that difficult alright so if
you have a look at these samples right
here these are examples of sets of
images now without actually caring for
top and bottom row they will have some
meaning right here the top row is always
a row from the actual data set and the
bottom row is the reconstruction of that
set now you'll see that this the images
don't really have a correspondence so
you see it's the same truck in the top
and the bottom row but the orientation
here isn't really shared or anything and
that's because as we said this is a set
Network so what you want to do in this
problem setting is you want to take you
want to build a model that can take this
set right here from the data set and it
can encode it into a latent descriptor
that we call Z Z simply describes the
set as a whole so Z here would be sorry
would be truck right it would sort of be
the the 3d model so not the class truck
but the 3d information of the truck
without having any information of the
different views okay and then you want
to build another model that can generate
from this low level representation of
the set can generate the different views
okay like each one of these by sort of
rotating it so we want to build a model
that understands just from the pixels
that here we have sets of things that
they somehow always share a commonality
and in this case they always share their
3d structure right what they don't share
is the view where they rendered from so
our model is supposed to kind of parse
the two apart and encode that 3d
structure just from the pixels in this Z
variable and then encode the fact that
you can rotate it and look at it from
different views into the generative
model that then produces the different
views okay and the reason why there is
no correspondence between the views is
we simply regard these things as sets so
our final objective is simply going to
be that the set on top as different
views of that particular truck is going
to be very similar to the set on the
bottom which is also different views of
that particular truck and that's what
our models supposed to do now
you might know something like this from
we can simply say well this this looks
like a class conditional again right I
simply have the class truck and I you
know I feed this to my generator and my
discriminator and my encoder and so on
and they will produce a the same truck
and here that and here the bench and so
on the problem I guess becomes more
apparent when you go to this different
data set so this is a
dataset and again top row being the
input and bottom row being the output
now what is here what is supposed to be
preserved you can kind of see in the
images is sort of the identity of the
person on the photo now you have two
kind of glass across around your human
bias here you as a human can tell
extremely tiny differences between faces
and therefore none of the actual
identities are going to be preserved
right so this on the top I believe is
Alli and on on the bottom here it's not
not Alli so but you'll have to sort of
gloss around this and you'll see that
what is preserved or what is supposed to
be preserved is something like the rough
identity of the person on the picture
and also a little bit of the image
compositions so you see here in the
background you will often have sort of
these sports backgrounds right where
there's kind of a washed out stadium or
whatnot and you can see that this is
also preserved here I think it's kind of
a glamour glamour shots of this must be
some sort of glamour model and you'll
see that this as well is preserved what
is different within each set is of
course the different views on the same
identity right so you have the same
person and you have pictures of them in
different of different views different
lighting different hairstyles and so on
here you even see you have the black and
white image and the set that is produced
also contains some black and white
images so this model this is already the
trained model here is doing a fairly
good job here you can see that almost
all the pictures have some sort of
double like two people with one being
sort of half in frame and it leads to
fairly fairly strange thing I'm gonna
guess the model hasn't seen lots of that
during Trey I like I particularly like
this this is this is pretty good also
here it we know that a lot of these face
datasets they don't really have
Balt people a little too often so you
can see here this results in sort of
kind of a weird richard branson type
picture in any case it does it does a
fairly good job right as you can see
right here and what's the problem with
with these faces can we just do a class
conditional again where we basically say
here this is Alli right and that's one
class in our latent vector and then and
so on what we want to do is we want to
train something like this that where we
can give in a new identity that we
haven't seen during training in fact we
want to train something where we don't
even know how many sets there are going
to be in the end right we simply want it
to want to train it in a way where we
say look I'm going to give you a set and
the set will have you know images of the
same person and you're going to sort of
reconstruct that in a way where you
output a set of images of that person
concerning conserving the identity of
the person and the rough style of the
picture so this is really different from
a class conditional again as in we don't
know how many classes there are and
there can be new one unseen ones during
testing so how do we go about something
like this and here here's where the
things start so we're going to dive into
a bit of of the math here and then into
a bit of the reasoning but ultimately
what they're going to do is they're
going to build and they are going to
build three things they're going to
build an encoder a discriminator and a
generator so what does the encoder do
and remember our task here is going to
be the way we train it is going to be by
reconstruction at least one way we train
it so the encoder is going to take this
set of images that we give it for
example here different views of this car
and is going to
Douce this representation this set
representation now what should this what
should it properly be of the set
representation for example it should be
independent of the ordering of these
inputs right a set is simply a
collection of objects it's independent
of the ordering and it's also
independent of the size in in some way
of course a bigger set gives you more
information but the set identity the
fact that this is this particular car is
independent of how many views you have
so what they do is they build and they
put each image through an encoder which
is a convolutional neural network and I
guess that that gives them a hidden
representation and encoding and
embedding for each image and then they
have this operation called pool and
binarize and so these but this does two
things namely first of all it pools it
simply averages these things so it goes
1 over N see I of X I or C of X I I
guess so this simply averages the these
these encoding x' right here and this
already fulfills our property so this
average is independent of the order of
the images and also I can add more and I
can add less in expectation the average
will result in the same thing right so
this here now we have basically lost the
information of the order the exact
ordering and so on this is simply an
average of these images it's a good
representation for a set this is now if
we give enough images this will be
independent of the particular rendering
position and it will only depend on the
fact that this is that particular car if
it's trained well of course and then the
second thing is binarize and here you
have to understand how these what
exactly this set latent representation
is how
we encode a set in latent space and as
far as I understand it as far as I
understand it what they do is they do
the following so since they don't know
how many sets there are they can't
simply do the classic one hot vector so
what you would do in a class conditional
gun is you would say I have a vector and
maybe I have ten classes so I'll make
ten entries right here is that ten I
don't know
I'll make so if I have C classes
I'll make C entries right and I'll put a
zero in all of them and the one in where
a one where my classes or something like
this so this would be a valid encoding
for a class conditional again to
represent the identity of the class here
however no we don't know
and also we can't really make this
continuous because other if you make
this continuous you you wouldn't really
encode the identity of the set it's the
you would encode more of you would
encode more of kind of a continuous
latent space and then that becomes kind
of different when you have new sets and
so on so what they really want to do is
they want to make this representation
here be a description of the set itself
but not a one hot so what do we do what
they do is they do the same thing they
have a vector but not of size C because
they don't know C but of some
dimensionality D okay this can be ten
this can be for this can be you know
whatever just let's say it's ten again
but we don't know how many classes there
are what the model can do is it can
encode each class as a binary vector a
binary combination of negative ones and
ones so it can put like a negative one
here a one negative one negative one one
one negative 1 and so on so
what what does that give you now you you
can encode much more than ten classes in
fact you can with this you can encode to
to the ten classes right and that's so
it's not like it's not the it's not that
they can encode an unlimited set of sets
I have set identities but they can
encode in this matter they can encode a
lot right they can encode this many sets
using a representation like this
so this binarize operation it will take
this output right here and basically
clamp it to either one or negative one
so the set will be encoded by a binary
vector like this and then the generator
and the discriminator take that
information okay and we'll go we'll go
over what what this architectural choice
means but right now this you you know
see that this is a this is a way to
encode a large number of set identities
in a low dimensional vector alright so
there are two things now there are the
discriminator and the generator so first
of all the generator is pretty easy
the generators task is to take this Z
that we just saw which is the set
identity and to generate different
instances of that set right and for that
it needs this noise here so if you know
a generator from a from again this it
always kind of needs input noise in
order to produce different outputs and
that's this thing on the right here this
Z prime they simply come from some sort
of latent distribution I think they call
this P of sy which is something like a
uniform or a Gaussian or something you
just sample some noise right and you
combine it with this thing right here
which is the set identity you
concatenate it and then each one of
these different Z will produce one
different one different view right here
okay so the generators task is simply
take the set identity and combine each
with some noise and produce some views
of that set
now the discriminators task right here
is going to be to decide it's going to
get a set of views of a set of pictures
and it's going to have to decide is this
set coming from the generator or is this
set coming from the data set right now
you can simply compare images to each
other like you would do in a regular gun
because they don't correspond to each
other right but what should correspond
to each other is this identity this Z
identity so the discriminator is going
to take also two inputs it's going to
take this set right here or you know
from the data set and it's going to take
this right here this is Z now this Z is
going to be the set identity and that
you get from the encoder right it's the
same as you get right here you get it
from the encoder which said you should
produce and the same goes here so the
discriminator knows the set
discriminator knows for example i'm
trying to produce that particular car
and it gets a set of images that is
supposedly of that particular car needs
to decide does it come from the data set
or from the generator so it uses the
same encoder pipeline here it's just
like a CNN giving you a latent
representation and then it has two tests
the discriminator has two different
tasks first of all this here is the
regular Gann path so it there's and
there's an MLP there's simply a pipeline
that outputs a number and the number is
does this come from the data set or thus
this come from the generator but then
there is an additional pipeline that
they have found to be vital to train the
objective which is a
reconstruction pipeline so this is more
like a sort of like an autoencoder
pipeline where they have a decoder they
try to reconstruct the input set and
they then compare it using mean squared
error now here they try to reconstruct
the input set really picture by picture
not as a set but picture by picture so
that's it's different from the set
generator okay and this is this pipeline
is just to stabilize the training but it
also goes into this the output of the
discriminator so sort of the
discriminator is happier the more it can
D the more it can reconstruct the images
which just seems kind of weird at the
beginning but it you know they say it
has helped in other Gans I'm not super
familiar with gann literature but it's
just say another objective that you can
add so this is going to be the overview
right here so if everything works well
we should be able to take a set from the
data set X right which is going to be
you know images different images from
the same person we should be able to
feed that to the encoder get a latent
representation Z for that set that
somehow encodes here the identity of the
person and now we don't
if the encoder works really well we
don't have to have seen that person
before it will simply somehow encode the
identity in that binary vector then we
feed that to the generator together with
some noise and we'll get out a set of
pictures of different views of that same
person or the person with a similar
identity and pictures with similar kind
of picture style and that if our
discriminator works well we'll look very
very similar to or will be images really
of that same person and our
discriminator if we plug that in right
here we'll agree and we plug in the Z
right here okay okay that's the overview
now the math so think about this in this
sort of probabilistic framework what
they say is we have we denote an image
set of size n as X and that becomes from
the space of sets of images so capital X
right here is going to be a set of
images as you see here and this here is
the space of all sets of images okay so
what they want to do is they want to
build a probabilistic model of that so a
model where you can input a set and
it'll tell you how likely is that now
you don't you don't actually have to
have a number as an output right here
what they often do is they start with a
formulation like this and what they end
up with is simply a model that allows
you to sample from this distribution
right from which you can estimate the
probability but ultimately what we want
is a generator that can sample from this
okay so how do they build it they
decompose this into two parts and this
is just a you know a decomposition this
is a standard decomposition of
probability where you'll say okay what's
the probability of a set X the
probability of a set X is the
probability of the latent code of that
set times the conditional probability of
that set given the latent code so
already we we have we ask ourselves
what's the probability of X and what we
might ask is huh well X you know if I
look at X it has these different images
of this this it has these different
images of that thing whatever is on the
image I can first ask what is the
probability of that particular thing on
the image and then conditioned on that
what is the probability that I'll get
these particular images right this is
this simple decomposition already kind
of builds up this model of
encoding/decoding so we'll go through
that step this here is going to be a
deterministic function our encoder and
this here is going to be a probabilistic
function the the decoder and it's
probabilistic because every time you
call it basically every time you call
the generator it's going to give you a
different output because you you're
gonna feed it different noise at the be
beginning okay so so this is going to be
this is going to be our end coder here
and this is going to be our decoder so
they say here X is a as Z is a
deterministic function that map's a set
X to an element in a discrete space Z
okay this is a discrete space as opposed
to maybe a a regular auto encoder where
you have a continuous space so here we
want to discrete space and a lot of
mathematical problems are going to arise
from the fact that this Z is a discrete
space and not a and not a continuous
space so here P is a prior distribution
with the support given by sub C which
means all the Z vectors that have some
sort of set associated with them which
is a subset of all the Z so that
basically means that if if we have a
given encoder they're not all of these
binary vectors are going to be filled
even you know with if we plug in all the
world's faces into our encoder it might
not fill all of the binary capabilities
that we have
so this prior is only defined on this
support of this and here you already
kind of see what what kind of
mathematical hurdles you have to go
through if you do something like this
and all the math here is going or most
of the math here is going to deal with
the fact that we have this discrete
and so on and a bit of a bit of a little
bit of of a caveat here also is that
this here they stay mentioned this here
is a prior you need a prior distribution
on your z variables and this is also not
easy so really quickly what does it mean
to have a prior distribution on this
kind of thing
because usually in a regular like auto
encoder variational auto encoder right
your latent your latent code you'll have
a prior on it and that prior can be you
know some some continuous thing like a
Gaussian and even in regular again as I
said you you have your your noise
distribution and so on what is a prior
on that thing now you can say oh a
uniform prior but again we would like to
learn this prior such that it matches
the data set well now they use a prior
from a paper that's called made em a de
and really quickly what it does is it
sort of kind of decomposes this thing so
what you'll have is a neural network
that outputs binary vectors like this
and it will sort of output them in a
fashion alter aggressively so it will
output one of them and then condition on
that it will output the next condition
on that it will output the next and this
is such that the probability of this
binary vector minus 1 1 1 minus 1 and so
on
is going to be decomposed into the
probability that there is a minus 1 here
times the probability that there is a 1
here given that there is a minus 1 here
and so on and in different order I don't
really want to go into this but just to
show you that there is a lot of
consideration of mathematical
consideration if you really want to go
about really want to go about this sort
of thing in a formal fashion so they
define two things first of all this
prior ok it's a prior distribution that
they can learn from the data set and
then
there is this conditional distribution
this what you might call a generator
right if you're given a Z a one of these
binary codes what's the probability of a
given set so you're I tell you here
it's a scarlet Johanson what's the
probability of these pictures being
different views of scarlet johansson so
that is going to be simply we're going
to build this as an energy based model
you can you can do this what you'll have
to do is you'll have to define an energy
and we will just quickly discuss what
that is and then you can build a
construct like this where you'll say the
probability of a given set is going to
be the energy that assigned to that set
divided by the energy that I'm going to
assign to all of these other sets so
this is it's a form of an energy based
model you can raise very many things in
terms of these energy based models and
Jung Lacan gave a talk about this at
iclear I believe where he gives a lot of
different examples of energy based
models so I invite you to check this out
I've also done a video on some of these
energy based models and what you can do
with them here it's simply to define
this probabilistic model so what we need
to do are two things we need to know
what is this energy so what is this
energy supposed to do this energy is
going to be a function that gives you
and now I have to think so its energy is
going to be a function that gives you a
high value if you are unhappy with the
input and it gives you a low value if
you are happy with the input okay so you
see the negative exponential here which
basically means if and also the energy
is always positive so so the best if you
are SuperDuper happy with what is what
your input is
to the function you'll output zero so if
you output zero here you'll see that e e
to the exponential function of negative
something is going to be quite small and
no maybe I have it wrong
maybe you output a really high number
when you're really happy I'm not sure
but it's one of the two so this comes
this comes from from a physics from a
physics background no no I'm right so if
you if you output if you're not happy
you output a super high number here
which will make this negative
exponential be really close to zero and
therefore the probability you say if I'm
not happy the probability should be
close to zero however if you're really
happy
you'll output a low number right here
now the energy always has to be greater
or equal to zero but the lower you go
the higher this probability is going to
be the bottom thing here is simply to
normalize the distribution because in a
probability distribution
you always have to normalize because
otherwise it's not a probability and
this is what most of these models
basically are fighting over how to
normalize the distribution and what
we're going to do is simply normalize it
by sampling which is what most of these
things do you can build energy based
models without this which ganzar a
variant of that but ok so what we need
to do is we need to come up with this
energy function that is going to be a
high number when we're not happy with
the input now what is the input the
input is x and z x and z what does it
mean we're not happy with the input it
means that the image X and you see X
here is one of the images of the set
that particular image isn't really
congruent with the Z with the identity
so you either you say what this this
isn't really a picture
of Scarlett Johansson so I'm going to
assign this a high value however if you
know if this is really any sort of
picture of of that person then you're
going to assign it a low value and how
better to do this than to build a neural
network to do that and this is going to
be our discriminator
so our discriminator is going to take
the role of this energy function ok cool
now
I said you need to normalize and I kind
of set it off the cuff and so on but the
problem here is again we have these kind
of sets and and so on so our probability
as you'll notice is the probability of X
given Z so we are already given the the
identity of the person so what do we
need to normalize by we can simply
normalize by all the sets of images in
the world like here it's in the integral
we need to normalize by all the sets of
images that are mapped to that same
identity ok so in order to normalize the
distribution we basically ask how likely
is this set how happy are you with this
particular set right here compared to
all the sets that could exist that would
map to the same identity all right
that's why these indicator functions are
here and as you can see the part here is
simply a normalization where you say I'm
just going to produce other also I'll
consider all the other possible sets of
images that map to the same person and
I'll simply divide by the energy of
those in fact if you do it correctly
this particular X is also in that
particular set but usually it's going to
be a fairly small part but to properly
normalize of course you have to consider
it as well now this bottom part here as
I already said is going to be the main
problem of most of these probabilistic
methods
and as I already said again it's usually
approximated by simply sampling a bunch
of these sets and not sampling a bunch
of these set and not a by enumerate all
the possible sets of images and this
sampling is going to make some further
problems as we'll see I guess down here
so here is what we optimize ultimately
we optimize or one of the things we
optimize is where are we okay yeah so
they say we apply maximum likelihood
estimates to estimate the parameters of
the thing we just defined where where
the negative log likelihood loss for an
observed set in the training split is
this so this is simply the negative log
likelihood the log decomposes into a sum
so this is going to be your prior and
this is going to be your generator
discriminator combo okay it's the
generator producing images from that
binary code and then the discriminator
assigning high or low values to that
produced images and also two images from
the data set and the thing over here is
simply going to be the prior over the Z
distribution that we briefly discussed
now again they have to have to do some
tricks here where they say okay we can
get rid of this support by using a
normalized distribution over Z which is
abound on that true prior and so on so
they're going to replace the P with ap
bar which is over the entire space of Z
and that's going to be a bound but the
interesting part I feel more is here
where they consider the loss again of
this conditional distribution on Z so
you'll see the exact same quantity right
here but now our loss
is going to be the negative log of that
now since it's the negative log you can
decompose the division into a sum and
and this part up here you will see the
indicator function here is a bit
unnecessary because the Z here is the Z
that we're considering is going to be
the Z of that particular set that we're
considering and so this equality holds
on the top so disregard this and this
down here as I said is simply a filter
to filter the space of all sets to the
ones that correspond to the Z that we
have in the energy function so this goes
here because it's simply a log of an
exponential and the negative signs
cancel so you'll end up with this what
does it mean you want to minimize this
loss right here and part of that is
going to be you want to minimize the
energy function of these inputs okay you
want you want to and this is now the
case when it comes to from the data set
right so when X and Z come from the data
set and E is your discriminator then you
want to make the output of the
discriminator really small which means
that you want to train the discriminator
to say I'm really really happy that this
particular image comes together with
this particular identity encoding now
the indie in de if it comes from the
generator of course you want to do the
exact opposite you want to assign it a
high value remember energy low means
happy with the input okay and then the
normalization down here is as I said the
problem so you'll see it stated right
here because it's under the the division
it's going to get it pick up a negative
sign which combines with this negative
sign which gives you positive sign right
here now this part right here is going
to be intractable because it it's not
going to be feasible to enumerate all
the sets of images it's not even going
to be
to enumerate all the sets of images that
just correspond to that particular
identity and in fact it's not even going
to be feasible to sample from that
because we have no clue right we can
simply generate out of the ether through
other pictures of the of a particular
person what we can do of course is we
can use our we can use our model to
produce more images of that particular
identity so what we'll do is we'll
replace this distribution with a
variational distribution and we'll
sample from that now this isn't exactly
the same this isn't this log probability
anymore and that's why first of all we
have a bound here and not an equality
this is this is called a variational
approximation so we bound this quantity
and we can only bound this quantity if
we down here introduce the entropy of
the variational distribution this is a
fairly standard trick in variational
approximation methods if you want to
look more into this look into kind of VA
e-explain variational autoencoders
explained or anything like this we'll
teach you how how these methods work any
case we replace a distribution with a
distribution we can actually produce and
what is that distribution look what
we're supposed to do is we're supposed
to produce a set of image given so sets
of images here given particulars E and
we can do that that's our generator
right so we can use our generator to
produce those samples and that's what
they say here here we've derived a lower
bound by introducing a variational
distribution which we parameterize in
the form of a generator okay so the
generator is going to produce that
distribution it's going to use this
noise production so as you know the
generator takes two things it takes the
identity encoding and a bit of noise and
is going to produce an output set or for
each noise it's going to produce an
output image very cool so that's that's
the the kind of math formulation behind
this model now they have a model
architectures right here but this is all
fairly standard except for so for the
prior they learned the prior on the z
space so you see you have Z being this
binary vectors they say we use a
standard auto regressive model made with
three fully connected layers mainly for
its simplicity and robustness and so
again maybe you like it took me a while
to get what this prior does this prior
is supposed to say it's so it's not in
again you have the Z vectors always
being some sort of from the standard
noise but what you can also do is you
can learn better noise distribution a
better input distribution for your again
by basically making again for your input
distribution so what you'll do is you'll
have a Z 0 right here and then you'll
use a you'll learn again to learn better
input distributions okay and this is
what you do here with these with this
prior on Z this is more standard in like
Va es than it is in ganz but it exists
so encoder se as a necessary option
encoder for a set needs to satisfy the
permutation variant property we opt use
a simple architecture design where we
let this be the average right here so as
you can see this is the average and then
they they use this binarize operation
and the binarized operation here is
clamping the values to 1 or negative 1
and it is a straight through estimator
which means that you will you back prop
as if you hadn't clamped but you forward
prop through it with clamping this is
kind of a trick to get through
discritization things discriminators job
is to assign low energy to observed
images and high energy to generated
images given a set code Z we use an auto
encoder based energy function
implementation similar to twenty five
and here they say we have found that
this choice is important as it enables
effective learning in early stages of
training so that's why they do usually a
discriminator would be the energy would
be equal to this thing right here which
is a small MLP that map's a the input to
a real sorry you can't see that that
map's the input to a real number their
high energy I'm not happy low energy I'm
very happy here they also include this
thing right here which is a decoder so
it's kind of a you can maybe think of it
as a another little gaen another another
another little generator or the the
generator part of a VI e or Auvergne
auto-encoders or not a V a an
autoencoder
that takes as input the encoding of the
particular image and the identity and
produces is going to produce something
that's close to the output against the
observe that this is now with respect to
a particular image so here we're trying
to reconstruct that particular image
because we have its input thing right
here and we're it's not the same as the
generator that is just asked to produce
a some view some thing that corresponds
to this particular identity vector okay
the generator generates a set
conditioned on a set code by sampling in
random variables each of which is
concatenated with Z and generates an
image independently cool so what are the
losses they they they now introduce some
margin losses on the things here
but basically you can just translate the
what we have on top where we formulated
a negative log-likelihood into the
losses right here they do have some
simplifications
for example this to train the prior you
what you or to train to train the
encoder I think you have to make a bit
of an approximation in that the encoder
is supposed to match this this Z vector
right and that's not differentiable by
itself so they have this sort of l1
approximation right here they leave away
the entropy from the loss and they have
found that to work well they introduce
this margin losses right here I I don't
want to go into that too much but
basically they simply in have a way with
some approximations they approximate oh
yeah here it is the indicator function
they approximated as this I was looking
for that they they they optimized this
log likelihood from above in the way
where they always optimize they keep the
generator constant and they optimize the
rest of the pipeline so the encoder and
the discriminator and the fryer and then
they keep that rest fixed and they
encode the generator so what does that
do before remember right here we had
this this approximation right here where
we said you know what comes out of this
we're not really optimizing these we're
optimizing we're minimizing a lower
bound on it right so here is a quantity
that we want to minimize but here's a
lower bound and we'll just push that
lower bound down by optimizing you know
that doesn't tell us anything about this
thing right here but there is actually
more to it so by optimizing the
discriminator and the encoder and so on
we do minimize this lower bound so that
this this loss right here you see this
energy function will adjust that
whenever we adjust our whenever we are
just our that particular
lost our discriminator will adjust that
energy function whenever we adjust our
encoder we are going to adjust the part
that generates these z vectors right
here so we'll push this down but
whenever we optimize our generator
that's when we make this gap here
smaller okay so we always do two steps
first we or first or second in one step
we reduce this and in the other step
we'll bring these two closer together
and as a result of course we hope that
it's not just the bottom one going to up
down up down up down but we hope that
both of them reduce with time because
the top one is the one who will actually
want to reduce that's our actual loss or
our log likelihood and that is I guess
going to happen in practice so what does
this do
so as I already saw here on top you have
a set and you feed that through the
encoder you feed that through the
encoder that gives you a Z identity and
then you feed that to the generator and
the generator you can ask it you don't
have to produce the same amount of
images you can produce any amount of
images you like they just chose to
produce the same amount there's no
correspondence but you see it's the same
truck and here they manually align these
so they just produce a bunch of images
on the left is the data set and on the
right I guess they just produced like a
hundred images and then selected
wherever the car looked like the closest
to so they ordered them by by hand and
that is to show that for example look at
the the lighting on the car right here
it's it's fairly similar I guess this
one has red taillights and the other one
hasn't but you can see that the the
different views are pretty well captured
by the generator and that just from all
of these are created from one one binary
encoding of this here so this is binary
encoded to Z and then all of these
different views are Korea
there's no image correspondence so
that's pretty cool and another problem
we have with sets is how do you evaluate
sets you can't you can't go and check
for images or image closeness and so on
so they have to do some 3d modeling they
actually take they take these images
right here and they have to approximate
their 3d shape and then compare that 3d
shape with the 3d shape of the original
thing in order to just a quant
quantitatively estimate how well they're
doing in the faces the the same thing
you input the top row into the encoder
and you get back the bottom row we've
already looked at that but again to
evaluate this they actually have to go
and use some sort of a face detector to
recognize is that even is that the same
person always and is it so you can
evaluate two things you can evaluate are
these right here all the same people so
you can have a a face detector kind of
tell you whether or not these are the
same people and the second thing is are
these down here the same person as these
up here right so those are the kinds of
things how you can evaluate this and
they've done this and it's fairly
interesting and the results here are not
surprising when you look at the images
so these are curves curves from this
face detector and of course for real
images as you can see the this is simply
the performance of the phase detector so
you do get some false positives if you
if you want more true positives right so
this is a standard curve right here
because these face detectors are not
perfect so in a given row right here in
a given row even if that's from the real
data set the face detector would
sometimes fail and say no that's not the
same person even though from the data
set you know it is though the the to
match the actual
photo from Ali with his adult photos is
even like you can forgive the face
detector
so that's sort of the the gold standard
we're trying to achieve and you can see
within the reconstructed sets that that
is achieved fairly fairly well so
compared to uniformed samples this is
you know fairly fairly cool fairly close
what is less close is this reckon and
real and I believe that's when you
compare the identity of the real row
with the identity of the reconstructed
row and that's here so that tells you
already that it's the Gann or sorry the
model doesn't always preserve the actual
identity as seen by a phase detector and
I don't know what to say except yes
that's what you see in the data right
also you see that free samples I guess
so you can do two things right you can
give it a set like a row and then code
that into the Z and then you can decode
that again and basically reconstruct or
you can just sample since you've learned
the prior on the Z variable you can
simply sample you can simply say give me
some new identity maybe that I've never
seen before right you have using some
binary vector and now generator please
give me like images of that identity and
these two here are actually sampled like
this and you can see again here it's
remarkable that within the same row it's
pretty much the rough identity of the
person is conserved right and these are
these free samples right here I guess
and they they do better than whenever
you compare the reconstructed and real
but they don't do as well as when you
actually input a real data and then
reconstruct this so this might be an
indication that this prior isn't really
working you know all too accurately and
I do have my problems with this binary
and coding right here because maybe I'm
misunderstanding something but if you
have these binary vectors as we said
here the reason you know the reason why
you do one hot encoding in class
conditional Gans is you could you could
simply say what what am i doing at one
hot encoding I'll simply say Z equals 3
for class 3 and Z equals 4 for class 4
like that it should be so easy why am i
doing one hot and that's because these
models see everything in a linear
fashion so if you're I have class 3 and
then I have class 4 and then I have
class 9 the model doesn't see that as
three different classes the model sees
this as these two are somehow closer
together tend this right so they're the
reason why we do one hot vectors is that
the model cannot do this the model has
one independent dimension for each of
the classes and whenever that particular
dimension is high then it knows that
that particular class is activated what
this binary encoding here does is sort
of it goes back to this thing right here
where it says okay there are all of
these different categories here it's
like you have mini classes and the
identity of whatever set you consider is
now encoded in these mini classes so
that I'm going to guess the the first
thing here might be something like does
that person have blonde hair and the
second thing might be does the image
look generally bright or the images
image set as a whole look generally
bright or dark and and so on so I'm
gonna guess these things are encoded
here in illa it'll sort of just end up
being kind of a discrete again or a
discrete auto encoder rather than what
they believe but maybe that was their
goal all along and I'm miss
misunderstanding right here I just don't
think this this binarization is
gives you the sort of hoped
expressiveness I think there's still a
lot of dependence of whether or not a
particular thing is on or off okay but
enough ranting right here I want to look
at the some more of the samples because
I've only shown you the reconstructions
what I also find interesting is the free
samples so here you can see on curated
shape net samples and on the left so
here you can see this effect on from the
learned order regressive prior and a
uniform prior on the right and here you
can see this effect of learning this
prior so if I learn the prior it's gonna
give me back fairly okay objects if I
don't learn the prior oh but if I learn
the prior you know if I learn the prior
really really well that basically means
I'm only going to ever produce sets that
were in the training data right if I
learn like a perfect prior I'll see like
wait this you know this particular
identity here never shows up so I'm not
gonna output it and the uniform prior
might actually output it and the
generator is not going to be trained on
that uniform prior so it's just going to
give you kind of crap and here in the
interfaces you see the same thing now
again what I think I don't think that's
happening what I think is happening is
encoding these kind of micro
characteristics not per se identity but
it's encoding probably you know a hair
color whatnot head shape and so on
things like this and in each of these
dimensions and that's what is then going
to produce so these each row here is an
is one sample from that prior on the
left is learned which you see is working
pretty well in terms of the output and
on the right you see it's from the
uniform prior now you also see here
first of all that approximately identity
is
serve but not as much in this uniform
prior that's first and second you'll see
that the images are much worse which
means that the generator doesn't have as
much training on that particular thing
because I guess it comes from a prior
that it hasn't seen during training all
right and here lastly they have
reconstructions if you give different
number of views so the top row I guess
is the input the this row is when you
just have four different views so I
guess just the first four or something
like this input and the bottom one is
when you have the full eight views and
you can I guess see or even more that
this increases with number of views so
the the accuracy of this identity
increases the more views you input of
the set and they have a bunch of other
things right here in the appendix I I do
invite you to look at this and I hope
you sort of saw into a bit how you would
go about something like this I I found
it quite challenging the math because
I'm mainly not used to this kind of
variational math but I hope this gives
you sort of an impression all right
this was it from me tell me what you
think and I'll see you next time bye bye